متر مكعب. لتنقل وزارة الدفاع
الروسية بشارة اخرى بان جلسة
ثلاثية انعقدت بحضور وزراء دفاع
روسيا وتركيا وسوريا في موسكو
من تصعيد النقابات العمالية في
بلد يعطي قيمة كبيرة لحرية
لمشاركة المرأة ببرامج عدا
الطبية والدينية فقط وبحجاب. في
الغلاء المعيشي لبؤس حالهم.
الحكومة البريطانية تحت ضغط
مأساوية انه النجم البرتغالي
كريستيانو رونالدو الذي انتقل
الاحتجاج. موسكو ترفض سلام
اوكرانيا المزعوم والصين تضع
وزير الدفاع التركي خلوصي اكار
ان تركيا لن تقوم باي عمل ضد
الدراسة الجامعية للطالبات
الافغانيات طالبان تقول لا
للعب في الدوري السعودي مع نادي
النصر في مفاجأة مدوية. بعد منع
الاضرابات وسوناك يغامر بمستقبله
السياسي ويتجه لفرض قوانين تحد
فرنسا اعاد بعض الفرنسيين بيع
هداياهم لعيد الميلاد بسبب
القدم البرازيلي لحاملي لقب كأس
العالم لثلاث مرات عن عمر ناهز
ودمشق منذ اندلاع النزاع في
سوريا عام الفين واحد عشر ليعلن
اثنين وثمانين عاما. بينما هنا
اسطورة اخرى ولكن بمصير اقل
السوريين المقيمين في تركيا او
داخل سوريا فيا له من تغير مثير
للمواقف التركية. الاحداث
والتطورات. رحيل اسطورة كرة
بحث فتح الطرق الدولية والسماح
للبضائع التركية بالمرور عبر
اليابانية تراقب تحرك حاملة
طائرات بقلق. وقالت وزارة الدفاع
الطائرات وهي تمر عبر المضيق بين
مياكو واوكيناوا الى المحيط
ليبلغ اجمالي احتياطي البلاد في
البحر سبع مائة وعشرة مليارات
الكوري الجنوبي لفشله في اسقاط
المسيرات الكورية الشمالية لتبدأ
الامريكية. كيم يغير طريقته.
سلاح واحد لا يكفي لضمان
طائرات مسيرة لتعبر الحدود الى
الجارة الجنوبية مما دفع سيول
جديدة للجيش لعام الفين وثلاثة
وعشرين. معلنا عن استراتيجية
قوات باجراء تدريبات لمواجهة
تهديدات الجارة الشمالية. تركيا
تجتمع باعدائها. بعيدا عن الحروب
ومهاترات الحدود وملاحقة اعداء
من الغاز الطبيعي تقارب ستين
مليار متر مكعب في البحر الاسود
الشمالية. ليأمر الرئيس الكوري
الجنوبي مساعديه بالانتقام من اي
يانج بسبب السلاح النووي. وذلك
وفق وكالة ينهب هناك اعتذر الجيش
واتفق الوزراء على تشكيل لجان
ثلاثية مشتركة كاشفة ان الاجتماع
استفزازات كورية شمالية تايلاند
يجب الا تكون هناك خشية من بيونج
الى ارسال طائرات مقاتلة وطائرات
هيليكوبتر هجومية ومحاولة اسقاط
النضال ضد العدو وملمحا الى عام
اخر من اختبارات الاسلحة المكثفة
المستقبل وزعيم كوريا الشمالية
كيم جونغ اون يكشف عن اهداف
كما قامت برد مماثل بارسال
طائرات مسيرة الى جارتها
الاراضي السورية. وهو اول لقاء
رسمي على هذا المستوى بين انقرة
البلاد. اردوغان يعلن بشارته
لبلاده باعلانه اكتشاف احتياطات
مسيرة المجنون. في اول اختراق من
نوعه منذ عام الفين وسبعة عشر
وخمسين قطعة بحرية مقارنة بنحو
ثلاثمائة قطعة فقط للبحرية
الجديد وهذه المرة لم يطلق
صواريخه وقذائفه ولكنه اطلق خمس
والتوتر وفق رويترز. ليبدأ
المجنون قبل حتى ان يبدأ العام
عدد السفن والوحدات العاملة
باجمالي نحو ثلاثمائة وخمس
الهادئ. تعد الصين بالفعل صاحبة
اكبر قوة بحرية في العالم من حيث
بعض خطوات بكين بعد تكرار
مناورات الصين تايوان ردت بتمديد
اليابانية انها رصدت سفن تابعة
للبحرية الصينية من بينها حاملة
الخدمة العسكرية الالزامية من
اربعة اشهر الى عام واحد. فهل
الغرب على تايوان. من جانب اخر
شنت بكين هجمة اخرى وبسلاح اخر
تتأهب لكل حركة وسكنة صينية. فها
هي قوات الدفاع البحرية
يكفي ذلك لردع اصحاب العيون
الضيقة? تايوان ليست وحدها من
ستمكنان بكين من خنق التجارة
العالمية في حالة نشوب صراع مع
يزال قائما حسب وكالة رويترز.
الصين تخنق الغرب. تتعدد الضربات
خوفا من الاصطدام لتصرح واشنطن
ان الصينيين يتبعون سلوكا خطرا
في اوروبا. بعد تأهب القوات
الصربية على حدود كوسوفو اعلنت
الاخيرة غلق المعبر الرئيسي على
الحدود مع صربيا. لكن عادت صربيا
امتار فقط من مقاتلة امريكية ما
اجبر الطيار الامريكي على الهروب
لتتراجع وتنزع فتيل باعلان
الرئيس الصربي الكسندر فوتشيتش
وفق رويترز. وبالعودة الى تايوان
حيث اعلنت حكومة تايبي عن رد على
حين اعلن جيش الامريكي ان مقاتلة
صينية اقتربت لتصبح على بعد ستة
العام الفين وثلاثة وعشرين الى
روسيا في زيارة ستكون الاولى منذ
الروسي ان القوتين تعتزمان تعزيز
التعاون بين القوات المسلحة
ورقة بحثية للاتحاد الاوروبي
تحذر من ان هيمنة الصين على
لروسيا والصين. ليعلن بوتين ان
نظيره الصيني سيأتي في ربيع
الرئيسي للمحروقات. ليؤكد الرئيس
الصيني ان التعاون مع روسيا
زيادة امداداتها من الغاز
للاقتصاد الصيني المستهلك
الامبراطور الكسندر الثالث الى
الماء. وتشير التقارير الى ان
الشحن الدولي والسيطرة على
الموانئ الاوروبية الرئيسية
ان الحواجز ستزال لتخفيف التوتر
لكنه قال ان انعدام الثقة لا
الاخرون وتمتلكه الصين. وهو قادر
على شل التجارة العالمية. هنا
بداية جائحة كوفيد ناينتين. حرب
اخرى تكاد طبولها ان تقرع قريبا
استنساخ جميع انواع الاسلحة.
ولكن هناك سلاح اخر لا يمتلكه
والزناد واحد وتتعدد الاسلحة في
العالم بينما تستطيع بكين
يمكنهم من تخطي التحديات
المختلفة. بينما اوضح الرئيس
الرد الروسي كان قاسيا حيث اعلنت
السلطات الاوكرانية تعرض عدة
الانتصار في ساحة المعركة. لكن
الرئيس الروسي يعد لما هو اعظم
قادرة على حمل صواريخ باليستية
عابرة للقارات من طراز بولافا.
بقوله ان بوتين يسعى لكسب الحرب
بكسر ارادة الاوكرانيين وليس
موسكو من المحاكمة. وها هو وزير
الدفاع الامريكي السابق يؤيد
لننتقل الى حرب الطاقة. وفي
الوقت الذي يبدي فيه الاوروبي
يا سادة. ويشهد تسليم الغواصة
الذرية والسفينة الصاروخية
الغواصتين المذكورتين تنتميان
الى سلسلة غواصات مشروع وهي
مقاطعات لهجوم بعشرات الصواريخ
الروسية بعيدة المدى ليخرج
الصغيرة وكاسحة الالغام البحرية
بينما تم انزال الغواصة الذرية
تصميما على التخلص من اعتمادهم
على الطاقة الروسية تحاول روسيا
زرنسكي مصرحا ان كل صاروخ يسقط
على الاراضي الاوكرانية يقرب
اوكرانيا اطلق من منظومة اس
ثلاثمائة التابعة لنظام كيانج.
دفاعها ان وسائط الدفاع الجوي
التابعة للمنسك اسقطت صاروخا
ليدعو الامين العام لحلف النيتو
ينس تلتومبيرج دول الحلف الى
وفقا لسكاي نيوز. وعلى الارض
اعلنت هيئة الاركان الاوكرانية
مقتل خمسين جنديا روسيا في
ميليتوبول وتوكماك ليستمر
الاوكران بهجومهم المرة بلا
روسيا هي الهدف. حيث اعلنت وزارة
زعيما ان الدعم العسكري
لاوكرانيا هو اسرع طريق للسلام
طائراتها الحربية من انجلز الى
مطارات اخرى. وذلك وفق متحدث
قوات اوكرانيا الجوية. لكن موسكو
اعلنت فورا انها مسيرات كييف.
تزويد اوكرانيا بمزيد من الاسلحة
لضمان انتصارها على اوكرانيا
المسيرة كانت قد استهدفت مطار
انجلز الروسي لتخلي موسكو
اوكرانيا لم تكتفي بالتصريحات
المتحدية لروسيا. هنا طائراتها
الزلنسي الذي صرح انهم يواصلون
اعداد قوات الدفاع وان السنة
الاوكرانية حالة التأهب الجوي في
العاصمة الاوكرانية كييف ومقاطع
هو الذي سيحسم الامر. الرد
الاوكراني جاء على لسان الرئيس
الجديدة ستكون حاسمة فيما يخص
المعارك. لتعلن السلطات
تحسبا بهجمات صاروخية روسية
واسعة النطاق ليلة رأس السنة.
الاوكرانية للوفاء بها. الا فان
الجيش الروسي في هذه القضية.
مضيفا الامر بسيط نفذوه من اجل
مصلحتكم. والا فان الجيش الروسي
حليف على الطاولة التركية وبعد
فوز السعودية على الارجنتين. كأس
تهديد روسي شديد اللهجة. كل قال
كلمته. وكل ادلى بدلوه في هذه
الحرب في اوكرانيا واطراف الحرب
يعلنون التحدي. ها هو وزير
العالم كريستيانو رونالدو الى
الدوري السعودي.
اوكرانيا تعرف ما تريد موسكو
جيدا وان الامر متروك للسلطات
الخارجية الروسي سيرجي لافروف
يرفض مقترح كييف للسلام قائلا ان
اردوجان يفصح عن بشاراته اخيرا
فيما سوريا تتحول من عدو الى
تتسكع طائراته في اجواء الجارة
الجنوبية وسيول ترد بقوة.
تستعدان زعيم كوريا الشمالية
يعلن اهداف السنة الجديدة بينما
الصين قادر على شل التجارة
العالمية وتايوان واليابان
منتصرة من الحرب في اوروبا حرب
اخرى تقرع طبولها. فهل سلاح بيد
وموسكو ترد. والناتو يعلن عن
اقصر طريقة لتخرج اوكرانيا
المعركة العام القادم. اوكرانيا
تستهدف الاراضي الروسية مجددا
الامر. قالت موسكو بغضب
والزلنسكي يرد. نحن نستعد لحسم
نفذوه من اجل مصلحتكم. والا فان
الجيش الروسي هو الذي سيحسم
الغرب بين كفيها. وكيم يغير
طريقة هجومه وجارته الجنوبية هي